Nestled in the quaint mountains above Hiroshima,...
...Maruni Wood Industry is a furniture manufacturer eight years shy of its centennial.
Maruni made its name in Japan by producing well-crafted traditional furniture.
And now, it's contemporary pieces also grace well-appointed galleries,...
...offices and restaurants around the world.
Maybe all the Japanese children are told, "God is always looking at you."
So, even though people never touch here, our craftsmen sand and finish it very carefully.
That kind of mindset or that kind of mentality comes from this God island, Miyajima.
When the family called Takeshi to return to his hometown,...
...he knew that getting the company back on track will be no easy task.
Maruni was experiencing the most difficult period in its history,...
...and the challenge was not only finding a solution,...
...but also convincing the rest of the family that this is the right way forward.
Of course, we want big sales,...
...but we don't follow sales.
We follow quality or we follow what we want to make.
Continuity is more important than big success or big sales, I think.
So, if we keep that kind of thinking, our company is needed in this society.
I am Yamanaka-san, so working for Maruni is my destiny.